okay now the astute among you noticed
that just like we've f of X or square
and one on f of X there are some
critical points one of which is zero
okay because the square root of zero is
just zero and of course the other
critical point is one I should have said
critical value so it's one which is
still about here right so the square
root of one also one so far so good
okay now then when you think about how
it's going to behave after that again
think visually right for example you
know what this values three
so therefore the transformed function
should be the square root of three which
is about one point seven okay
so you're looking at somewhere just
above halfway ok now even just from this
very cursory drawing you can see that
it's sort of curving over this way right
curving over this way which actually is
exactly what you ought to expect right
because think about it like this when we
did our original y equals f of X or
square okay we identified our zero point
we identified our one point and then we
said well it's gonna do from here to
here what all parabolas do which is
going upwards like this okay so this is
like a zoomed in version of that so you
can see it goes underneath and that's
critically important well because what
you're looking at here is the inverse
version the inverse function of squaring
okay instead of going underneath your
original curve
you're gonna go just above right at
least in this little area here between
zero and one and then you're going to go
off and you're going to do your normal
thing okay because this graph has
discontinuities in it by the way it's
got an endpoint you should describe how
it ends can X equal negative 1/2
can it exist it or can it not do you
have this scenario what do you have well
let's try it shall we
x equals negative 1 and 1/2 see what
happens y equals the square root of 2x
plus 3 by definition which is the square
root of 2 times negative 1/2 which is
negative 3
Plus 3 which is the squared of 0 does
that exist it does exist right it's zero
so I need to describe that on my graph
with a filled circle must be filled in
ok
whenever graphs end and they don't just
keep on going forever you have to say
how they end and if we have determined
for whatever reason that it couldn't
actually exists at that point of course
you would give it a hollow circle
instead okay last one
very quickly you think whoa we're doing
this modifying Y business again which is
so confusing before ok but remember I
told you there was this link between 8 &
9 right what's the link yeah if you take
the square root of this right because of
the Y squared is over here I'm going to
have you slap up plus minus over here
right so therefore all this is is just
that which we already know it looks like
that okay that's the positive part y
equals positive oops square root of x
but now I also need to include the
negative part which we looked at it was
the very first question with that this
morning how is it different it's the
reflection across the x-axis and you're
like oh of course because it's just this
guy right which we you seek the depth on
this is just the sideways parabola as we
looked at on the locus right so of
course it should look like that that's
what you would expect